the three of us have finished control
now and there is a lot to unpack so we
decided the three of us because we
finished it we'd get together sit around
a couple of mics and dig in to this game
will spoil the heck out of it so if you
haven't finished control yet I would
click out save this like this video come
back to it later and make sure to let us
know what you think but Peter you
reviewed it gave it an 8 out of 10 top
level what are your thoughts on control
a great quintessential remedy experience
that I've been waiting a long time for
especially after playing quantum break a
couple years back which was okay but
this is just far better than okay it's
really great and maybe more than that
mm-hmm and Shawn you finished it as well
yeah I'll agree with everything you just
said except the quantum breaks a little
better than you put it but control
definitely brought something that
quantum break was missing and that you
know Alan Wake had in the past yeah I
mean I think having finished it we were
talking about a little bit a little bit
on the podcast games what after dark I
think it might be my favorite remedy
game
Alan Wake is tough to beat agreed just
because of the the atmosphere of the
setting but I think at the end of the
day I was way more invested in control
there they have there's one big
difference between the two games and
that's the setting right where control
is set within this single location I'll
be at a big one with a lot of different
things
Alan Wake was pretty much like you know
a lot of nature right a lot of being
outdoors and but yeah it there's that
common foreboding mysterious sinister
force being inflicted upon these
characters and they don't really know
why or what it's capable of and and
you're along for the ride and goddamn is
it fun and interesting yeah I mean I
guess why don't we start with the
gameplay since I think that's probably
the easiest to digest yeah from this and
one notable thing is how it builds over
time right like when you start the game
you're not really doing much you're just
shooting enemies maybe doing like the
little homonym like in the face you know
melee attack yeah but uh eventually you
I mean Jesse Faden becomes
superhero pretty much yeah it doesn't
take too long like I'd say the first
power she get is the ability like pick
up objects from the distance and throw
them in the - and - yeah but yeah once
it starts to click it's this fascinating
juggling act between gunplay and certain
powers yeah for sure yeah and I think
this is what it definitely sets it apart
from Alan Wake is I feel like it plays
it's more fun to play I really do like
Alan Wake but I don't look back on the
gameplay as much as like the story and
kind of like the cinematography of those
scenes and whatnot but this one like if
I was gonna play another one I would
want to play something like control it's
just a lot of fun when those things are
meshing together
yeah replaying Alan Wake I know you've
been doing the same to you you have
these great but like the story is great
the characters are great and then you
get to the combat and it's not the
combats bad but I feel like they're just
long stretches of going through the
forest and and aiming your flashlight at
enemies which is fun but you're just
running out of breath and keeps running
out of breath yeah but this is far more
frenetic and fast pace and you really
feel in control glad we're both thinking
the same thing yeah I yeah playing Alan
Wake right now like a little bit in my
spare time and it's like I could just do
without to comment control really does
make it shine and it's also like a
technical kind of showcase as well for
Remedies Northlight engine I think it's
called yep yeah it pushes the current
consoles to their limit it seems but
playing it on PC unhindered it is just
beautiful it's amazing like how chaotic
combat can be it really feels like a
battle is taking place right like you're
not in a plastic environment you're in a
reactive environment yeah yeah just
seeing yeah exactly like after you get
through a battle and you've been pulling
pieces off the wall and throwing it at
enemies and then once the dust is
settled there's chunks of the wall
missing tables are broken it's it's
impressive I walk into a room even
without combat I walk in and I see like
an array of desks and I'm like pick
something up and get across the top and
watch all the staplers and documents and
desks just like fly it's or like I love
just dashing through things cause like
they'll just shatter yeah
you guys how many times did you have the
map open want to close the map and end
up just dashing forward into something
maybe a couple than that all the time I
will say though there is something very
satisfying about the first time when
you're in a fight you're like crap out
of ammo I'll try the grab and you just
pick a chunk of the wallet for the first
time it's like oh I have I have ammo
forever I can grab anything and attack
what this is awesome yeah yeah I knew
the end I think I relied way more on my
throw opposed to any of my guns cuz it
puts so much more damage and it's just
satisfying like especially when you hit
some of those enemies and they backflip
and yeah the gun the guns really do feel
like and I will say maybe the charge
shot more than anything else is
impactful but every other gun kind of
feels like a stopgap while you're
waiting for your abilities to yeah get
more juice so you can use them again mmm
right I don't I didn't use like the
charge shot at all my primary was the
pistol the pistol was just really good
yeah and the Pierce because I could
shoot from like forever far away oh is
that the one I'm thinking of
that might be the thought has that ones
like the proximity like EMP sort of
thingy yes yeah that's what I used to
especially on those floating guys
because if you didn't pay them and you
could just shoot them right out of the
sky and they all right that's exactly it
yeah yep so I mean that's the gameplay
but I think the real meat of this
discussion is going to be the story and
what that might be about now I don't
think any of us have concrete ideas of
exactly what happened or what happens
throughout the game apart from you know
what you witness so there there's a lot
to discuss I don't even know where to
start let's just set it up like who's
Jesse fade right Jesse fading you know
she enters this building she's got this
inner monologue going on where she's
like I don't never exactly what she's
saying but she's talking to herself and
there's a suit as a poster and behind
the poster there's something that creeps
out every now and she's like she like
even references like Shawshank
Redemption at one point yeah she's like
that movie where they escaped from the
prison amenity and she's like Shawshank
Redemption that's the movie I was
thinking of I was like cool all right I
was like good a told you that and
talking about yeah it said that that all
poster on the wall thing I'm still kind
of struggling with that a little bit but
the the idea of this conversation she's
having with her
self and another entity another force
some people in the office for like Oh is
she breaking the fourth wall and talking
to me no that's what I thought at first
yeah really and then she starts actually
talking about Polaris okay I feel like
maybe I was like paying too much
attention to like the lead-up to this
game where I was just like no there's
something else that's that's driving her
in her thoughts and stuff I guess we'll
wait until we get into what that is but
one of the first things that happens
after she you know she enters his
building and it's like her first day on
the job and it's like where is everybody
you know she goes through a metal
detector and you guys look at the notes
next to them you had wears like no
archetypal typical objects allowed like
X Y Z no cancels no smartphones and ever
and and the reason why they don't have
smartphones is because new technology
explodes in there cuz the the history
whatever that's going that I don't know
the the oldest house just doesn't
interact with it I don't know if you
found that doctors I dunno yeah it must
be where there's typewriters everywhere
yeah what year is this as there's a
bunch of evidence that's like 2014 I'm
like yeah but there's no computers or
anything I forget the exact document but
yeah it was like don't bring any of
those because for some reason the oldest
house just does not get along with that
kind of equipment isn't there so staying
on topic but you're reading a little bit
the idea of like archetype you know like
objects I'm going to Google to kind of
like look into the background of some of
these concepts like the idea of
archetypes and union psychology showed I
saw this image of the idea of self and
it was represented by a character figure
looking into a mirror and seeing
themselves and like yes that's me
that's the concept of self and then Rob
Hanley were saying like if you noticed
aren't really any mirrors in this game
yeah like Jesus got that far like there
I never even noticed yeah yeah so
there's like all these little touches
like that and so she goes into the
building there is one mirror right so
she anyway but she walks in and like she
meets Otte this janitor who you can
understand about half of what he's
saying yeah estimates mumbling subtitle
that's a cheap yeah he's immediately
intriguing and he's kind of confusing
the situation because you know you're
there for a job but he says you're there
for an interview to be his assistant and
it's kind of
okay where are you are you there for a
job I thought you had just found this
place and you were just kind of like
investigating no you hear all there for
a job yeah I missed that one then I mean
she knew she's been in the place before
oh I must have missed that cuz I thought
she wasn't able to get to this building
until she had needed to that was the
point of the oldest house I think she
was taken away from it at one point but
I know we're getting ahead of ourselves
here isn't she one of the threshold kids
quote unquote yeah yeah it wasn't that
back in in ordinary oh was that I
thought that I thought they had done
that I could be wrong right yeah no I
mean maybe I'm mixing things up but I'm
sure I am and I'm sure we're all mixing
something up because this story's pretty
twisted but yeah the idea of threshold
kids is a series of tapes that as I
interpreted it based on this one note
was that the show was made to help the
kids that were living at the oldest
house because they were vectors for this
kind of crazy [ __ ] and they had to
be contained to allow them to cope with
where they were okay so we there were
videos using puppets to help the kids
have like a proxy for themselves dealing
with difficult situations that makes
sense to me it presented in a really
creepy like but so she travels into the
office you know runs in this janitor and
then ends up going in the director's
office and he kills himself right before
it so just to backtrack a little bit one
of the interesting things I noticed
replaying the beginning was that she
after she has that discussion with the
janitor and she starts moving she says
something to herself about something
about his face or something like that or
the face of things and he responds to
what she says in her head yeah I didn't
notice that the first time I don't know
what to read into that but I was like
whoa maybe there's well I mean obviously
there's more to this janitor because
he's the most one of the most
interesting characters in the game but
still I was like yeah there's something
I missed about why he can understand
what's in my head
yep I'm still not really yeah like he
said I still hard to figure out where he
fits into all this I wouldn't be
surprised if he's like the most powerful
character and like this were entire
world right cuz even there's tons of
documents of being like if you noticed
the Jenner doing doing this I'm here
exactly how did he even get through this
thing yeah yeah well yeah like after you
get through the maze yeah there's like
notes like how the
the janitor yeah yeah yeah so Otzi's
great and then yep you get to the
director and he quickly offs himself and
it's this I think it creates this weird
Delta of understanding where you're like
am I gonna end up killing myself yeah
but do you actually kill himself or was
it somebody else like I have a voice in
my head did he have a voice in his head
but then very quickly as you start
exploring past that then the he starts
talking to you through these like
visions that manifest on the screen and
it's once you get the hotline right the
hub is it well he doesn't forward - yeah
okay you'll get those FMV show but you
can't I don't actually maybe you still
can rewatch him but I don't know I think
you need you might need a hotline to
rewatch things I think that's correct
and watch other scenes that they add as
well yeah but I just decided not-- -
like getting into Easter eggs a little
bit but as you guys know is that as
James McCaffrey who voiced Max Payne and
he's also featured in Alan Wake so
they'd like to use him a lot for sure
mm-hmm
don't if there's anything else there but
I mean there are a ton of very explicit
connections but I think I should wait a
little bit to get to that yeah frankly
this story I think after that part with
the director it becomes really vague for
a while there's a lot of kind of
exploring understanding the rules of the
world right like what are altered
objects or objects of power
oh they're other people still in the
building that are not crazy like they've
got these devices that protect them from
the hissed they have their own
objectives and their own kind of ideas
about what's going on we should mention
that kind of Jesse's core goal is
finding her brother who she believes is
somewhere in this building right yes
which I don't know for me I felt like
that wasn't the focal point like for a
while and then it did become the focal
point like for me is the player not
necessarily her as the character yeah
well even like kind of early on she says
something something along the lines of I
want to be here like it's not about my
brother it's it's because I need to be
here so there's you know more than that
as well yeah how did you guys feel about
the side characters other than the
janitor like the what's-her-name oh I
always want to color Emily it's hi Emily
it's just Emily right is it only a
blonde yeah
okay is it Emily hope yeah yeah or Emily
Pope
Emily Pope really good at our jobs yeah
but but that's kind of the thing a lot
of the side characters I thought were
interesting but I never really like
wanted to get to know them except the
janitor I would say and Dylan who I
spent a lot of time talking to and that
was strange
their presence though confirms that
what's happening isn't just all in
Jesse's head yeah right or that like
some of it is unique to her alone that
for me was like an interesting point of
reference like moving moving forward
like where I would have a strange idea
but then be like but wait a minute know
that real person experienced it as well
so they can't just be an issue that
jesse is only coping with but some of
them get really interesting I think like
I forget her name but at some point you
you can find this basement that goes to
sort of like a natural underground
environment like seemingly beneath the
oldest house the boldero yeah and I
didn't do much down there is too
powerful for me I haven't gone back yet
it's it's oddly difficult that area even
though it's not that long it's like a
couple sections and then there's a boss
fight but the basic enemies that are
there they're deceptive because in
multiple ways one because they like
embed themselves in the ground until
they're ready to fight you and then it
kind of like slowly lurch up and you
think oh it's just weak you know
poisoned vulnerable enemies but they
they they fire these like projectiles
that are really hard to see and they do
a lot of damage
some of them are like zombies but then
the projectiles can do a lot fast yeah I
got to the point where whenever I'd I
just keep dashing because I wouldn't be
able to see them a lot of times gonna be
focused on shooting something else yeah
but once once you get down there like
you see that I didn't go down there for
a while and you see this mold throughout
the building and it's like any time you
try to enter a room Jesse's like taking
damage and stuff and you're like okay I
can't go there I beat the game before I
ended up going down which you don't have
to do it in that order but I go down
there and there's like a scientist who's
like working on mold and she's alright
well I need you to go collect some stuff
here's some pills to make it so that you
don't react to the mold and what's
really interesting is how Jesse like
she's like this mold smells kind of
delicious yeah she like gets like this
hankering for the mold and the scientist
is like
I forget her reaction to but just the
whole interaction is super
and she's like upset when you beat the
mold boss because you've like yeah well
she says yeah Jesse returns and she's
like yeah it smells really good I can I
eat it and she doesn't say not to she's
just like oh yeah that's what happened
to other people they ate it and then you
kind of assumed that oh so the mold
smells good so you eat it and then you
turn into one of those things she says
how did you see this I know that's my
crew yeah so you're killing them but to
that point to like you know the hiss
the most part like employees at the
Federal Bureau of control that have been
turned by this power a lot of them are
just kind of floating in the air mm-hmm
right harmless but always whispering
always whispering really you could never
because something's just whispering yes
she says it like Burroughs in you yeah
and this stuff that they say like you
kind of get more of a sense of it once
you start to meet Dylan but they add
really interesting atmosphere to just
like an average area because there's
just people just floating there like
lifeless but then out of nowhere will
materialize these other enemies that are
way more you need to pay attention to
them or they will kill you in this game
can be tough I'm gonna be punishing I
guess is the right for sure that's where
like my biggest issue comes in was the
checkpointing system there was a number
of bosses where I would die and I'd be
so far back away because it would bring
me to whatever the last fast-travel
spot was and that might have even needed
me to fight enemies before the boss
which is just like the worst thing in
games when I can't just like try again
immediately that was like my biggest
noise yeah there was that one fight well
it was one of the last fights one year
and I probably don't to get into like
the exact details yet but when you find
Polaris and you're climbing up the that
one so that one particular because I'd
get to the last section
and then I I die because I have my
shield up and sometimes you'd get hit by
one thing and you'd be done especially
the guys hell rocks yeah they do so much
damage I had to choose that one but the
difficult part about it is that if you
wait too long between killing enemies
and activating the button that raises
the next platform's enemies will respawn
yeah yeah and you can't like just ignore
them and hit the button because they
will kill you yeah no I definitely had
to like start that fight jump back a
section and then I
just like sniping them with the Pierce
and I was it took like ten minutes and
it was super cheap but it finally got me
through it yeah exactly
yeah I think the idea of like using all
your powers is pretty important as you
go I think Jake we talked about the
smoke the podcast we just recorded but
like people who are having a hard time I
say well are you using it your shield
it's like no like are you are using seas
and it's like no no for me those two
things actually make a big difference
even though they don't back seas was
especially useful in that fight because
you get one of those people flying
around shooting rocks at you close to
death ending you cease them and then
that would distract the other one so you
could deal with all the other enemies in
the in the room seas I definitely leaned
on quite a bit I rarely ever used the
shield and I probably should have but I
just muscled my way through it it was
the only way for me to like get when I
needed health to just sheriff protect
myself yeah you got a right speaking of
there's kind of hard bosses did you guys
do the anchor with the vomiting clocks
one that one was pretty cool I must have
missed that or powered through it and
moved on to the next things I don't
remember it I haven't seen it there are
still a couple places on the map I
haven't been so maybe it's there sure
that one I thought was was pretty hard
I still haven't beat Nick I need to go
back and try it again but and remember
just not doing like any damage to it and
then it would just keep vomiting clocks
on me
oh that's cuz there's a certain way
there's it's got a weak point that you
had okay so I assume there was something
and you have to you have to well at
least I hit it with I use like levitate
or whatever to throw something at it I
didn't shoot it and it's like one of
those things or you just got to hit it
five times in that specific way so you
can't it's not just like a bullet sponge
yeah but anyway kind of like back onto
the story I mean one of the the enemy of
the game right is the hist it a sense of
exactly what that is where it came from
like it came from a different place and
comes into our world through objects of
no the altered objects of power
right and there's altered world events
right correct and then there's there's
altered items too and it came through
altered items right was it came to the
projector yeah that's what's that's
correct
that's correct but there are some times
when like the doctor actually
mentions like I think objects of power
and alter world events as like
interchangeable causes for the hiss like
coming through in a particular way play
sometime I don't know what the hiss is
really do you guys it's just like a
malevolent force right in some way yeah
yeah and there's no if we can know what
it is necessarily the but the former
does the former have anything to do with
it
you guys already mean by the so yeah
that's the that's the the snake [ __ ]
boss thing right have you done the
fridge yeah I've done the fridge I
didn't know how to name because I
thought that snake thing like twice okay
yeah yeah so it's called the former okay
and what that means I mean the former
must mean something it there's a there's
a with a hotline there's a log for it to
I don't know if you watched it about the
former and and they described it I think
it was [ __ ] I don't remember exactly
what they said the form was but it
wasn't a lot of information it was like
yeah the former is here and it is
basically the opposite of us and it is
trying to destroy the board so could
that not be then be this source it could
be part of it yeah
I I'm kind of curious cuz you said you
might fight the former multiple times
right someone told me that they fought
it a second time well kind of seems that
way I've only it was you yeah cuz I
haven't found the the streetlight or the
yeah you you fight it twice because over
the fridge and then the second one is
the Flamingo I believe which is the if
you haven't done the streetlight you
still have another set of those to do
from Langston's yeah I just started
though and then the last one is the
Flamingo and that leads to a harder
fight of that okay so what happens after
you beat it then just kind of the same
thing they were just like hey that thing
was that thing with the one I was there
again and Langston's like oh yeah we you
know we've heard about that so that's
not a little surprised that we knew more
about it because Langston doesn't did
you check the hotline after I wonder if
there's more information about it well
we do know that there is an expansion
coming in development that will continue
the story so I have to imagine it's
somehow linked yeah it's like jumping
ahead again but it's pretty obvious that
there's an expansion coming based on
that they say it yeah they're like the
your jobs not finished it's like -
expansion coming
Remis yeah I think that'll be like a new
wing of the building I hope it'll I hope
it'll just be in the astral plane or
something yeah we on the other side I
really hope so because we just as to me
that just sounds like combat challenges
which I wouldn't want I'd want more
narrative kind of stuff well they're
good still be narrative tied to that
completely I think like it's just I
think the purpose of like what is the
oldest house in terms of how it serves
the the actions that you're taking and
and the game leaves you with basically
like well you better clean up the oldest
house of all the hiss which I don't I'm
still not sure how that works out
because I was like going to rooms and
like shooting the floating people out of
there thinking like well if I get rid of
them maybe their chance will like if
they're gone and that room won't have
any more connection to that like that
force and maybe that's the whole point
but like I feel like they were popping
back all right yeah I'm assuming when
they say there's like more to do it's
kind of just like you can keep playing
at this but like the game is over
there's no way to get like a hundred
percent clear that's mine no no this
thing says expansion well no but I mean
like you because you're trying to like
actually clear out the hiss entirely and
I'm saying I doubt you could do that
that was probably just fluff to be like
hey well I mean I guess going back to
Jesse alright do you think do you think
there's more to talk on Jesse because
one of the like I feel like when you
find Dillon you've learned more about
her and her past in ordinary and you
were even saying that like I I'm curious
for you to explain battlin weak
connection to ordinary way there's an
Allen weh connection or yeah I miss this
well so it's not in a game back when
remedy was talking about making Alan
Wake - and it didn't happen because of
whatever reason he was like yeah I mean
the idea was it was gonna be set in this
town called ordinary Oh so therefore I'm
looking at control as holy [ __ ] this
comes after Alan Wake to whatever Alan
Wake 2 is so good star and focus around
Jesse and those even if she's not the me
like that projector to an ordinary or
something cuz interesting huh like yeah
that makes a lot of sense because I
think more so than any other they they
reference Alan Wake more than any other
remedy game yeah and plus so the the
play there's a these
scenes where Jesse performs rituals and
she's like transported back to this this
hotel or motel or motel the Ocean View
mode yeah which feels very akin to
something in the Pacific Northwest I was
like this this seems like the Twin Peaks
Sheriff Department right exactly
the only thing though well I mean
obviously what their original pitch for
Alan Wake to write was that it would be
like a desert town but I can really
actually see that well there's an
American Nightmare which was kind of a
deserted yeah but but the the the pitch
because I think polygon did a thing
recently where they showed remedy showed
polygon like 15 minutes of their oh yes
yeah and that was supposed to take place
in a desert town but once again that's a
pitch like things could have changed you
know but still even that hotel looks
like a hotel you could find and you know
driving through the middle of nowhere in
America you're in the desert and all of
a sudden there's a hotel called the
Oceanside hotel and there's no ocean
nearby but you know that's what tourists
might want yeah and so for Jesse like
that location is from memory it
correctly sort of like the the the
catalyst for like what happened to her
and Dylan his kids and why they got
involved with like all this
investigation of the paranormal begin
with but I am honestly wait you're
saying Jesse and them went to the Ocean
View Hotel because I thought they went
to the astral plane kids no well he's
saying that in the real world
I think Ocean View toes might be an
ordinary right is what you yeah but
because they mentioned that it's no
where they like look and there's
documents saying like no they can't find
where the Ocean View Motel is it doesn't
exist on the map but but it is ordinary
anymore right but at least that was
definitely a place like they recreated
it and stuff
did I just mean like from where I was
picking up the understanding was the
Ocean View Motel like doesn't physically
exist but they can get to it because
they had other like people from the
oldest house going to it and talked and
experiencing it what if it exists
because Alan Wake wrote about it yeah
maybe that could be the thing yeah who
knows I don't know the game makes it
tough I mean it it can as I think we're
illustrating you can really depend on
the documents you find and what do you
read into them I think it's a good segue
to talk about more of the connections
with Alan Wake it it seems like Alan
Wake was an altered world event did this
game
you know we kind of recontextualizing
yes Oh what did they say the objective
power was they said the lake itself
right in Alan Wake was the or was it the
thermos
well I the thermos was part of it too
because you find it and his manuscript
was as well because you find both of
those in the panopticon behind well you
found the thermos right you do find the
thermos and you even even get one of
those like pictures of it like you do
for all of the like altered items yes
definitely one of them did you find it
in the pen opticon no did you find it I
don't know where I found I definitely
did find the thermos at some point cuz I
found that secret area which I was
telling you guys about yesterday where
you it's like on the top level the
panopticon you have to have levitate you
fly over there and you find a note and
you read the note and it was like this
is all we could understand from the page
the rest was scribbled out and it was it
was like this is from Alan wakes
manuscript and then you walk closer to
it and then just like you see the
director that's silhouette that happens
with Alan Wake and he reads the page to
you like his voice actor interesting and
then right next to it there's the
thermos too anyway that's very it's very
obvious they're going for an Alan Wake
connection here you find documents you
know apart from everything else you just
said on top of that you find documents
that refer to him refer to his wife
right yeah and I wouldn't be surprised I
don't exactly remember how American
nightmare ended but I wouldn't be
surprised if like he's still somewhere
in the astral plane because the end of
Alan Wake he's trapped in there like he
trades himself for his wife to get out
really okay that's and then he stays in
the cabin and underwater or whatever it
is I wouldn't be surprised if maybe
that's how we can talk to you is maybe
people in the astral plane can so I need
to go back and play both on why can't I
I don't think I ever finished American
Nightmare I should probably do that well
from what I remember though it wasn't
super story heavy coming out of the know
and like it was a lot of like repeating
the same section over and over with as
it got shorter so it's a it's a pretty
short playthrough um I'd also recommend
that DLC for Alan Wake was beautiful as
well play those so Dylan so Dylan you
guys talk to me about Dylan because I
feel like there was a moment in my
playthrough where I kind of like stopped
paying attention and then it was like
wait a minute now he's in a coma
[Laughter]
what what power does he wheeled over the
various pieces that play so he's he's
definitely special like Jesse yes so he
can interact with the whatever entity's
going on the powers but in a much
stronger way than right and regular
people the history using him right yeah
I can amplifier more or less right which
is what kind of happens to Jesse at the
very end but she has Polaris she gets
out of it one thing I'm kind of confused
about is Claire is good or bad because I
feel like at one point you're it's good
for the most part it's bad in that fight
and then she's like wait maybe I
shouldn't of done that we get she goes
back and forth a couple times and I got
a little lost I'm not even exactly sure
what Polaris's other than a huge object
yeah but also what that thing was empty
right right it looked like it was a
straight-up I think they even comment
like it wasn't even in there right and
it was like oh what
but utility yeah how's it yeah I mean
you guys mentioned Dylan kind of like
invading your head I mean there's that
false credit sequence right in the
credits roll in Jake hit me up and you
text from him and he was like I think I
just got the bad ending in a JRPG in
this game and I was sitting there and I
was like three is there the credits
start rolling and it really does feel
like that just to sort of like I guess
it's over but nothing yeah well
especially like like that's acute going
back to Alan Wake but Alan Wake sending
I thought was pretty abrupt especially
without the DLC and I was like oh don't
do this again and and then it kept going
to one of the more interesting parts of
the game a short part but it was yeah I
don't know like so that was her trapped
in the history that was what it's like
to be in the hiss right and it's implied
that that's kind of like what happened
to trench which caused him to shoot
himself but then there's also the part
where it was Jesse that shot him so was
she did she shoot him Dillon was also
there so there's some kind of like loop
maybe possibly happening yeah she does
do her hand mind thing to Dillon at the
end and that puts him into the coma
right so we don't know if he's good or
not he's got to have something to do
with whatever's coming next for this
game why else would he still be around
yeah just to look at yeah well I know
you missed it but if you go chat with
him you can keep chatting with him and
chatting with him and chatting and you
do it for a long time and every time
it's just like I had a dream and hey and
he'll describe these very odd and weird
dreams but one of those dreams was that
I had a dream that you were my assistant
and we were you were my you were my
assistant and I was the director at at
the the FBC and we were we were doing
the same things every day over and over
and over and over and over and over
again and at the time I was like what
the and then but but when you get to
that that he's like describing the
hysteria just doing the same things over
and over and over again her trying to
get out of it so that's an interesting
little connection I guess and then how
does that all work with people who are
seemingly normal who are stuck in this
scenario like how are they not how are
they not referencing the fact that like
that that like jesse is caught in this
loop they never say anything to her
yeah that regardless I took that as this
was all just in her head like she's
stuck in this fake head do you beat the
game they're still there you can still
talk to them they can still work with
you like if you've effectively broken
free of that doesn't that fall outside
of that right I wonder if everyone who
you do fight is similarly trapped in
some kind of like a looping yeah well I
think so I think that was the point like
that's the hissed and then the hiss has
you you're just you work at the FBC
right you you like you work in the
government FPC where you're just
delivering mail or cleaning up mugs that
never seem to disappear right yeah yeah
yeah yeah but the people who are in the
existence that you're playing most of
the game in are not doing those things I
mean they're wearing things protecting
them from yeah the HRAs are aware of it
like it's a thing that that that is real
to them and as you are real to them and
not oh well
they even comment like oh weird you
don't have your Atari on I guess you
don't need one huh yeah okay so the the
HR either that is it's basically like
the Polaris thing that is channeling
that to protect other people right I
didn't know it's connected to Polaris
yeah you know there's a giant HRA right
before you
into Polaris that you have to shoot down
oh that's right yeah so doesn't that
just hold it this and that just
containing maybe maybe that's what it is
it's containing what's in there I don't
know I in my head I was just like oh so
they all have that it's got a giant or
no I guess right that would be
protecting it from the hiss that's what
I yeah okay that makes more sense yeah
what else talk about it I do think we
should talk about the maze yes my
favorite part of the game I thought that
was super cool and you know the
developer remedy cuz as soon as it's
done she like takes off the headphones
and she's just like that was awesome but
he'll just like break that down so you
get to a place called the ashtray maze
yeah and you get it early on did you
guys go to it before you like really
could do it totally yeah and you just
kind of run in a circle over and over
again have no idea what to do I mean and
there's like there's paintings on the
wall or photos on the wall like of the
maze and I was thinking like okay well
if I look at if I look at the one on the
wall then that means the wall will
dissolve or reopen on this side
basically it's like you're going down
hallways and walls are opening up or
closing around you as you progress and
yeah I was trying to find some sort of
logic in there right I was pushing that
for a while and they do do that in other
ways well I was trying to beat it to I
was like maybe if I - it maybe do my
like super punch through the wall I
could make it right yeah you can't get
anywhere with that and then eventually
what's that what's the super weird area
it's almost forest like or where you get
the headphones well that's that's the
other thing I wanna say but that's the
janitor when the janitors on vacation
it's like right you're following his
little like orange yeah it's like this
dark black pit with pillars and you see
an ocean and he's just hanging out down
there yeah he gives you a hold Walkman
like a tape player with like his buddy's
song or I forgot how it refers to it but
then yeah it's like this rock song that
I guess if you're wearing it will like
fight the maze or open up the maze for
you yeah and that what I was just so
cool it's like a it's not a good song
but the energy of it it's it's like it's
like a like a cathartic just kind of
like release because yeah like
that means you were trying to go through
oh my god I'm finally going through it
and holy [ __ ] there's a bunch of combat
and there's all this rock-and-roll
happening around me like right and
remains to the self is super cool like
floors will just open up or a giant
pillars will come out like it the whole
reality is like completely destroyed
inside of this maze it's like it's like
a fun house which yeah the oldest house
is not fun part in that way it really
doesn't breathe another thing too that
we should probably talk about because we
mentioned it earlier was that there is
one mirror in this game yes I liked as
far as and it that even more feeds into
what prob when you were saying there's
no mirrors but there is that one mirror
that is the reverse of Jesse and it is
like the literal verse I don't know if
you guys interacted with the the the
tape play there but all that was
reversed yeah yeah yeah cuz so the
premise on that is they sent an agent
into the mirror he came back and he's
like talking backwards and they're like
we can't understand you and then when
you go into the mirror you can go to the
same tape and now you can hear him but
the people outside are all backwards so
you get the other half of it he's like
there's something in here like you got
to like lock that down and then you
realize ah there's a fight coming of
some kind of some sort and then Twin
Peaks speaking yeah so at this point now
we've all finished the game where are
you guys in terms of going back in are
you trying to scour the environment for
any missed notes is that something you
interested in or you just reading the
ones you have are you just hanging out
fighting stuff I'm still looking for
notes I'm looking for I'm trying to do
all of the side stuff because it seems
like for the most part a lot of that
seems pretty interesting not the not the
stuff that pops up every now and then
like you got 20 minutes to clear out
this room or whatever but they're right
it stops annoying the the side stuff
like finding tracking down the altered
items because first of all they put you
in a position where you find different
bits of lore that you may have missed
and then second of all a lot of those
boss fights are pretty cool like there's
some really cool side bosses like the
former we talking about the plant thing
which and then the the anchor is really
cool the stoplights pretty interesting
it's not really a boss but it's just a
cool way to interact it's pretty obvious
they just case you do it but it's like a
stop go yeah what about you Peter are
you still playing it yeah I'm trying my
best to find little notes here and there
and I keep finding them and I was fairly
meticulous I'm at my first playthrough
but the the nature of the map in this
game is that it's not very helpful and
yes in the sense of really dissecting
where you have or have not been because
basically you enter like a general area
and it's like sick you've done you've
been to this area but it's likely what
about that little office or what about
that you know I'm still finding like
level six doors like oh I have many
areas this thing is red you know it
means I haven't unlocked it do you find
the door with all the office just with
sticky notes everywhere yeah did you
find the note about that yeah have not
seen this guy he's like who the hell put
all these sticky notes all over my
office or you like Larry blames it on
you know objects of power something like
that but it's just this really is like I
can't work here anymore
did you find the office they like see it
no I haven't seen it's literally like
it's just a normal office but every inch
is a post-it note that's great you can
see they're gaps between them so you can
like see what they're on but yeah it's
yeah the whole game is pretty dire but
remedy definitely had fun with like what
would be just something silly that would
happen in this like era are having like
a book club in here and people just
getting upset or they didn't read the
book club right this week or there's
those posters everywhere too that are
like just because the just because the
location of your meeting is changed due
to the building doesn't even your excuse
for being late
yeah or there's one about like hey I've
been you know I've I've worked really
hard for my position why is there still
no executive bathroom anymore I know it
moved but could someone at least tell me
where I went so we keep bringing it up a
guy's so pissed off they play really
they play around really well with like
that all that and that comes through a
lot in the FM bees as well I think the
the videos that are embedded throughout
the world that last one before the final
boss the music video oh yeah that was
weird a member if I watch them it's in
the Ocean View Motel it's the last time
you go there before the very end it's in
like the third room it's like the song
is like Jesse's the bomb and yeah yeah
yes it's like an 80s video yeah
the doctor yeah yeah it's like is you
just couldn't stop watching like I
couldn't stop watching I went in and I
was like all right well I have to label
keytar and stuff it's very good
so then what about dr. darling too cuz
he disappears right you don't meet him
at all but you get very used to who he
is and he explained the HRAs yeah a lot
of the game to you do you have any idea
what happened to him no I could see that
being like the DLC like he's trapped in
the astral plane you got to get him or
someone I'm sure I'm wrong there was
like a time where I was like where I had
one of those like director kind of like
mind invasion things and I was like why
do I feel like I'm looking at the doctor
like why do I feel like that's him isn't
that trench well I know you hosed to be
trouble but like my brain was just like
if I look at this hard enough I'm
grasping at straws here I totally
realized that and that's the hundred
percent probably not the case but I
don't know like there's got to be like
cuz there are videos where he's like at
wit's end right yeah he's in his
underwear yeah cold sweats and
everything yeah I just yeah I have to
feel like he's involved somehow yeah he
was too important of a character for
them not to actually have like a finale
to whatever happened to him so it's got
to be in the next thing or it's got to
be coming something well that's
everything - I wonder if there's just
like you were saying I wonder if there's
info that some of us may have glossed
over missed that maybe not explain it
but gives hints as to what could happen
to it because I kind of thought like I
thought he just got swallowed up in one
of the projector and the projector
whatever and he's just like chilling in
there or something like that has
swallowed him I don't know I want to
make the the board right where you put
up all the gears when you draw lines and
stuff like I I need someone to do that I
need I want to hear it from them because
I just feel like if you miss one thing
you're gonna get 10 things wrong about
the story or the character yeah there's
a lot to it for sure yeah and I'm a big
dummy
me too I'm excited for those hour-long
YouTube videos of someone who is oh yeah
dedicated their three months of research
to figuring out exactly and they'll
still be things they're missing it'll
frustrate them anyway I mean I think
that's our Oh is there anything else
worth bringing up or do you think that I
think one thing in the real world that's
kind of interesting is this website as
PC or the SP yeah I did mention that I'm
kind of getting like turned on to it
today and I'm trying to dig into it more
it's been a kind of a busy day but this
is essentially like a repository for
fiction that kind of deals with all sort
of world events and objects of power in
a way and it isolates them as like
different cases and you know it's
obviously it's all fiction but the way
that it's written and compiled pretty
much feels like a collection of
occurrences and analysis and what became
of that and some info is redacted it's
it's really interesting like there was
one about basketball where it was like
the DVR recording of this basketball
game was effectively a thing that people
could tap into and the observer when
they watched the game could actually
change the outcome and so people would
watch the game start it over but because
they knew it so well the score would be
like zero zero and they like we're
trying to like okay well was it the game
or was it the DVR so they watched other
things on the DVR like no that didn't
have it it was literally this one
recording of this one game on this one
DVR you know like and we had to stop
testing because everyone involved in the
project ended up you know getting really
kind of like you read in a lot of these
notes in control it was like and the
testing stopped because the subjects
were experiencing distress and mental
pain in English yeah so the website is
SCP - wiki net but yeah it seems like
there's a lot of interesting a lot of
the same lines as control yeah sure one
thing that I would like is I don't know
maybe when you beat the game an option
to turn off all of the redacted stuff so
you could go through the notes and see
so at some point in those notes it'll
always say like for more information
refer to document XYZ yeah I feel like I
was finding
when I was like looking back at old
materials I collected that like there
was less that was redacted because maybe
that was because I found a different
document oh that's another thing I kind
of need to look into a little bit more
but I maybe again my brain was playing
tricks on me but I really felt like okay
wait a minute
this I definitely read this before and
there definitely didn't didn't have this
info but it's an object of power all
tonight administrative power I don't
know I don't know these are all the
questions I have super interesting I
never even really thought to like look
back at previous ones again it could
just be me you know reading into nothing
but yeah I'm excited to see what like
the subreddit on this game ends up
finding because I bet there's just a ton
of stuff yeah I want Remy to be like no
it's supposed to not make sense there is
no cohesive hold everything like that
David you're like what does the race
read music I'm not telling
anyway that is control that's our
spoiler chat there we it probably didn't
answer any of your questions so but
hopefully this may be I don't know maybe
there's answers to some questions that
we have that you found out you can leave
in the comments below and if you have
any theories whatever let us know else
how wrong we are yeah I would love to
know how I am because that'll get me
closer to the truth
so please yeah alright thank you Peter
Thank You Sean bye all bye
[Music]